YOU OF WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
THANK YOU, DAN.
GREAT TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.
>> YES, SIR, YOU GOT IT.
>> Tucker: THE WORLD'S CREEPIEST
PORN LAWYER IS FAMOUS BY
ATTACKING DONALD TRUMP PERSONAL
ATTORNEY MICHAEL COHEN.
HIS OWN PAST BUSINESS VENTURES
ARE OUT.
MICHAEL'S INVESTMENT FIRM BOUGHT
IT OVER 9 MILLION AND SINCE THEN
HIS COMPANY WAS NAMED FOR MORE
THAN 50 OR STATE COMPLAINS
INCLUDING WARRANTS FOR UNPAID
TAXES.
A VENATTI CARRIED OUT AN ILLEGAL
PUMP AND DUMP AND RUN ACTUALLY'S
COFFEE SHOP AND DIDN'T PAY STATE
AND FEDERAL TAXES OF HIS
EMPLOYEES.
ASHES VEN
ASHES VE
ASHES --
ASHES -- A
ASHES -- A RE
ASHES -- A RENA
ASHES -- A RENAT
ASHES -- A RENAT TH
ASHES -- A RENAT THAT
ASHES -- A RENAT THAT T
ASHES -- A RENAT THAT TIM
ASHES -- A RENAT THAT TIME
ASHES -- A RENAT THAT TIME I
RESPONDED THAT KNOLL WAS
UNETHICCAL LAWYER.
BUT MICHAEL A VENA TTI CLAIMS
THAT ACTUALLY'S COFFEE IS UNDER
NEW OWNERSHIP.
AND YET LAST YEAR HE LISTED
HIMSELF AS CHAIRMAN AND
PRINCIPAL OF TULLY'S.
AND NOT ONLY BUSINESS TAX LIENS.
THERE WERE SEVEN YEARS OF
PERSONAL TAX LIENS STATE AND
FEDERAL FOR 1.5 MILLION AND
INCLUDING A 300000 FEDERAL TAX
LIEN FROM JUST THREE MONTHS AGO.
TUCKER?
>> BIG LIEN.
TRACE, THANKS.
>> BIG PROGRAMMING NOTE.
LAST NIGHT WE MENTIONED THE
CREEPY PORN LAWYER THREATENING
PEOPLE AND GOT US THINKING AND
ACCORDING TO THE WASHINGTON FREE
BEACON BETWEEN MARCH 7TH THAT
GUY WILL APPEAR 108 TIMES.
THAT IS ACCORDING TO ONE SOURCE.
VENT AVENATTI SDPSHGS AND WE
INVITED THE CREEPY PORN LAWYER
ON TO THIS SHOW.
AND WE CALLED HIS OFFICE.
IT MAY BE A WHITE CASTLE, YOU
NEVER KNOW.
AND HE TURNED US DOWN FLAT.
TOO BAD.
MAYBE WHEN JED ZUKER OF CNN
TIRES OF HIM HE WILL RECONSIDER
HIS OFFER.
WE ARE JOINED BY SOMEONE WHO
CLOSELY FOLLOWED THE CAREER OF
THE GUY WE TALKED ABOUT.
JULIAN EPISTIEN IS HERE.
>> GOOD EVENING, TUCKER.
>> THE ARGUMENT FROM DEMOCRATS
FROM DAY ONE IS THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP IS TOO SHADY TO BE
PRESIDENT.
THEY ARE NOW USING A CREEPY PORN
LAWYER WITH A HISTORY OF
FINANCIAL PROBLEMS.
IS HE THE BEST STANDARD BEARER
FOR YOUR MESSAGE, WOULD YOU SAY?
>> I THINK MICHAEL AVENATTI HAS
BEEN EFFECTIVE ON TELEVISION AND
ADVANCING THE INTEREST OF HIS
CLIENT AND USED TELEVISION MORE
EFFECTIVELY THAN MOST LAWYERS
DO.
I AM NOT SURE HE IS EIGHT
STANDARD BEARER OF DEMOCRATS AND
I THINK THE STORMY DANIELS IS
A SIDE SHOW.
THERE IS NOTHING IN THE
CONSULTANTATE STORY AND ANY LAWS
BROKEN.
BUT THERE ARE RELEVANT QUESTIONS
WAS IT USED FOR A RUSSIAN SLUSH
FUND OR A CAMPAIGN SLUSH FUN OR
LAUNDERING MONEY AND LOTS OF
THINGS THAT PEOPLE ARE ALLEGING
AND NO EVIDENCE OF.
>> Tucker: AND RIGHT.
>> THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF LEGAL
VIOLATION.
I THINK IF I CAN FINISH THE
POINT.
THE CENTRAL QUESTION FOR
DEMOCRATS ARE CONCERNED IS
WHETHER THE PRESIDENT KNEW OR
WAS ACTIVELY IN RUSSIAN
INFERENCE.
AND THERE NO EVIDENCE OF THAT.
>> Tucker: I AGREE.
AND I THINK THAT IS A CENTRAL
QUESTION.
AND THERE IS NO EVIDENCE A YEAR
IN AND MAYBE WE WILL FIND OUT HE
TEAMED UP WITH PUTIN AND STEAL
THE ELECTION FROM CLINTON.
PROBABLY NOT.
BUT RIGHT NOW IT IS ALL ABOUT
THE CREEPY PORN LAWYER.
WHAT IS THE POINT OF THIS?
I DON'T KNOW WHO HE REPRESENTS
OR I WOULD BE UNCOMFORTABLE IF
HE GOT AHOLD OF MY BANK RYDERS,
WOULDN'T YOU?
>> YOU NEED TO FIND OUT HOW HE
GOT THE INFORMATION, TO BE
HONEST, TUCKER, YOUR INDICTMENT
IS OF THE CABLE INDUSTRY.
IT IS OBSESSION.
CABLE INDUSTRY.
BOB MUELLER AND THE DEMOCRATS
ARE NOT NECESSARILY.
>> Tucker: CABLE RESPONDS TO
RATEINGLIES.
I DON'T THINK HE'S BEEN ON THIS
CHANNEL.
I WANT TO MEET THIS GUY.
>> HE IS COME ON.
>> Tucker: HE'S TOO BUSY ON THE
OTHER CHANNELS WHOSE VIEWERS ARE
RESPONDING AND THAT'S WHY JEB
ZUKER HUT HIM ON EVERY DAY.
AND HE WORKED ON THOSENS OF
DEMOCRATIC CAMPAIGN.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
>> I DON'T THINK THAT IS WHERE
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS.
WHAT AVENATTI IS DOING IS
RELEVANT BECAUSE IT GETS TO THE
CAMPAIGN VIOLATIONS.
AND WHETHER CONSULTANTS WERE
MISUSED AS A RUSSIAN SLUSH FUN.
>> Tucker: HOW WOULD A CREEPY
LAWYER KNOW?
WHAT EXPERTISE IS IT HE HAVE.
A RUSSIAN SPEAKER.
>> I DON'T WANT TO GET OFF OF
THE SUBJECT.
MICHAEL COHEN'S LAW FIRM HAD
A CLIENT WHOSE PRINCIPLE
BENEFACTRY WAS A RUSSIAN
CONNECTED TO PUTIN.
>> Tucker: WHAT DOES THAT DO
WITH THE PORN LAWYER?
>> I DON'T THINK HE IS
A STANDARD BEARER FOR DEMOCRATS.
WHAT THEY ARE SAYING NOT
IMPEACHMENT OR THAT TRUMP
VIOLATED CRIMINAL LAWS.
GET THE FACTS ON THE TABLE.
>> Tucker: LET ME ASK YOU.
WE ARE ALMOST OUT OF TIME.
WE'LL FIND OUT HE TEAMED UP.
BUT LET ME ASK YOU ONE LAST
QUESTION AND PLEASE ANSWER
HONESTLY.
PICTURE YOURSELF STANDING IN
YOUR KITCHEN GETTING A GLASS OF
WATER AND YOU LOOK OUT IN THE
BACKYARD AND THERE IS A CREEPY
PORN LAWYER.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND?
>> I LIVE IN AN APARTMENT
BUILDING.
>> Tucker: WHAT IS YOUR GUT
REACTION AND YOU SEE THAT'S GUY,
HOW DO YOU RESPOND?
>> I WOULD INVITE HIM IN BECAUSE
I HAVE A LOT OF THE QUESTIONS.
IF I SAW ANYBODY OUTSIDE OF MY
KITCHEN HAVING MY LAST GLASS OF
WATER, I OF COURSE WOULD BE
CREEPED OUT AS WOULD YOU.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
NO, I AM AN OPEN MINDED MAN.